after weeks of uncertainty a long-
awaited return for these Tha
Nationals since the ceasefire we don't
know much about what's happening I want
to encourage the Thai hostages who are
still held captive in
Gaza released captive utan thanked
authorities for bringing him home and
asked the crowd to observe a minute's
silence to commemorate the 39 ties
killed in hamasa October the 7th attack
on
Israel most come from Northeastern
Thailand they were among the thousands
of agriculture workers employed near the
Gaza Strip before the war broke out
Bangkok says it's doing everything it
can to bring home the remaining Thai
Nationals held captive by Hamas it's
working with Qatar Malaysia and other
countries to secure their release the
government has instructed journalists
not to ask the group about the
conditions of off their
detention lampong pinalo left her
Village in the early hours of the
morning to be at the airport for her
son's arrival when I first heard that he
was safe I was so happy I simply
couldn't speak I was just so happy
others are waiting for their loved ones
to return to their
Villages friends told me that buam was
released we were all so happy we
couldn't sleep we woke up her mother and
I told her mom Tom was released you will
see him
soon some are preparing for festivities
cooking elaborate meals to
celebrate we will have a ceremony for my
son because he was terrified by the
experience we will bless his spirits
waiting for her son to return has been
painful this woman says now she hopes he
will rest and finally feel safe at home
Jessica Washington aler Bangkok